Bonjour Madame, vous attendez quelqu'un ?
Oui, oui, j'attends quelqu'un !
D'accord
Merci
Salut Sabine, ça va?
Oui ça va et toi?
Ouais très bien
Vous auriez pu faire un effort
Ouais mais il y avait marqué "urgent"
Ça vous a pas empêché d'être en retard
Oui euh j'ai fais aussi vite que j'ai pu
En plus vous êtes même pas rasé
Ouais, désolé
On pourrait peut-être s'assoir, c'est un peu long ça fait...
Oui oui assieds-toi Maxou
Et en fait il était pédé
Bon appétit
C'était sûr
Ouais ouais la tuile
En même temps un mec qui aime pas le foot et qui remarque ton épilation de sourcils
Bah c'est forcément un pédé
Et sinon ton voyage?
Euh il paraît que c'est magnifique Istanbul
C'est trop beau
Par contre qu'est ce qu'il y a comme arabes
T'es con
Nan mais c'est vrai attends...
Ils sont hyper aggressifs
Ils sont sales
Ils sont toujours là à te tenir la jambe pour te vendre des babouches ou des tapis
J'en pouvais plus
D'accord d'accord
Et t'as rapporté des choses de ton voyage? Des souvenirs?
Ouais
J'ai choppé le peignoir de l'hôtel
Brodé, tout doux et tout je l'adore
Ah non merci c'est gentil
Non ça nous intéresse pas!
Allez dégage
Dégage dégage dégage...
Puis tu passeras le message à tout tes cousins là
Oh
Il pue hein
Eh
Tu sais que pour eux
C'est nous qui puons?
C'est marrant non?
Non
Qu'est-ce que je te disais?
Ouais l'hôtel, l'hôtel
Le service était top
Nikel
Tu me diras c'était tenu par des français
Normal
Il y avait quand même quelques employés...
Hein...
Mais
Triés sur le volet
Très présentables
Au bout de quelques jours je laissais même les bijoux dans la chambre
Rien n'a été volé dis donc
Bah si, toi t'as volé le peignoir
Ah mais ça n'a rien à voir
Ah oui d'accord donc y a que les arabes qui volent en fait
Oh ça va je déconnais
C'est bon on peut plus rien dire aujourd'hui
Olala
C'est comme ces féministes là toujours à gueuler, à monter sur leurs grands chevaux
Moi elles me sortent par tout les trous celles-là
Ouais moi c'est toi qui me sors par tout les trous
Mais qu'est ce qu'il te prend?
Il me prend que je peux pas te laisser dire des conneries pareilles
Eh oh dis donc
Tu te calmes Maxou hein
Mais j'en ai rien à foutre de ça, y a pas de "tu reste calme Maxou"
Tu dis de la merde, tu pense de la merde
T'es de la merde
Mais ça va pas de me traiter comme ça?
Je te traite comme je veux, t'es une connasse Sabine
Ah bah ouais t'es choqué
Et pourtant je suis français, je suis blanc, je suis trié sur le volet
Et bah je te le dis t'es une connasse, voilà
Hein
Donc tu vas te faire cuire le cul avec tes idées de merde
Je me barre
Salut
Attends
Attends-moi
Quoi ?
Je suis désolée Maxou
Je suis vraiment désolée
Déjà si vous pouviez arrêter de m'appeler Maxou, ça me fout les nerfs
Okay
Qu'est ce que vous me voulez encore?
Laisse moi t'expliquer
C'est pour le boulot, je suis cliente mystère
Okay?
Je suis payée pour dire des trucs horribles que je pense pas du tout
Pour mettre les e-buddies à l'épreuve, les tester et voir s'ils sont pros
Et bah bravo vous avez gagné, je suis pas pro
Hein
D'ailleurs je suis sûrement viré
Mais non!
C'est toi qui a gagné
Je t'invite à dîner avec moi, ce soir, hors boulot
T'es un mec bien Maxou
J'ai envie de te connaître mieux
C'est gentil
Mais ça ne m'intéresse pas
Je suis homosexuel
Ah bon?
Mais j'aurais jamais pensé
C'est bizarre
T'as l'air hyper euh...
Normal quoi
T'es vraiment gay?
Non c'est pas vrai
Mais merci
J'ai failli tomber dans le panneau
Maxou?
Il est parti...